on est énervé on est aussi triste et
perdu on est perdu
vraiment c'est ça des sentiments
collants
n'ont pas assez fort pour exprimer ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
était mon ami le dernier concert on l'a
fait ensemble c'était quelqu'un de très
très gentil très chaleureux et qui
chantait qui voulait juste chanter en
fait
encore une deuxième fois les méthodes
étaient assassiné donc pour cette raison
on réclame la justice en 2013 on n'a pas
éclairé la chutes on n'a pas éclairé les
choses et jusqu'aujourd'hui c'est
toujours dans le flou moi quand j'ai
déjà appris ce qui s'est passé moi je me
suis mise à pleurer tout de suite parce
que je me suis dit mais ça se passe
encore et je me dis c'est une rue on y
va tout le temps en famille ne serait-ce
que pour aller boire un thé un café et
je me suis dit mais ça recommence et
peut demain ce sera peut-être nous ou
vraiment quelqu'un de famille
nous avons très bien que
c'est un attentat terroriste le motif
raciste ne peut seulement être retenu
que l'État français n'attendent pas de
nous qu'on n'y croit à cette version
il s'agit d'un assassinat politique il
s'agit d'un assassinat terroriste il
s'agit d'un assassinat orchestré par la
Turquie de reggae Erdogan
[Musique]